i am not allowed based on our marriage
laws and
the the contract we signed with each
other right to have
anybody else right so these urges that
come i have to share them with the one
person i decide to spend the rest of my
life with
right so that that brings me back to my
my my sound bite
okay right i don't understand and this
is what we can discuss
as a woman because i don't i don't want
to say it's a man versus woman thing but
a lot of women do complain oh my
husband's always on me why is he always
on me
if there's going to be a chore for you
that you don't really want to do
why do women constantly push monogamy
on men if you know that you don't want
to have to deal with him all the time
just wanting you
why do you push monogamy on that well
who's to say i pushed anything on
anybody
like well we know that you pushed
monogamy on me i pushed me nothing
i forced you to get married to me time
out
i didn't say you forced me to get
married but did you not say to me
that you wanted to be engaged and you
wanted to be married
before you lived with me i want a
billion dollars i don't mean i'm going
to get it
i can walk one last thing but not you
something wrong
i see your face twitching and itching i
don't agree with the fact that because
you requested it
she's pressing it on him he was able to
about any anytime you want if
it's not what you wanted and i also
don't necessarily agree that women
press monogamy on men it's just that
it's a conversation that we do not
have okay i'm almost gonna disagree with
the first two the the last one that's
women definitely pressure men for
monogamy all the time
all the time for exclusivity they they
they're pushing for it they
ask for it they they keep yeah
asking something is not necessary
repeatedly i can understand that
yes yes yes
yeah yeah or even sometimes they go into
it friends with benefits we cool
and then all of a sudden you know they
start to catch feelings and they start
pushing like
but what if we were exclusive and they
start doing that and here's the thing
asking you're right asking is not
pressure but
but but but but asking is not pressure
you're right but there's ways in which
you actually understand right that
emotional aspect where you're like
i'm feeling sad or whatever so you know
what one thing you know one thing
play the video and i'm gonna stay in my
lane they're married i understand but it
doesn't matter i don't know
their situation i know mine and we don't
have the full
on i'm basing myself on the clip so yeah
it's hard for me to be like yeah this
isn't that that and blah blah
i don't feel like i was adequately
prepared for marriage and i've said that
before because if i knew
that marriage and monogamy was going to
involve me trying to meet you where you
were at sexually
for years to come then i probably would
have reevaluated it if i wanted to be
monogamous anyway so that's fair but
we're not even even talking about
marriage
let's even talk about dating right okay
two people are dating
typically in society who asks for
exclusivity first a woman or a man
i would say a woman thank you that was
my whole point see you were going all
over the place if women
typically ask for exclusivity first then
when they get
exclusivity say he always on me he
always want to have
why are we asking men for exclusivity if
we do not want to participate
it's set for sex at the same level as
men we have to think about
what that does to a man you know you
know what it's like it's kind of like
when someone's like let's
start a business together and then once
the business comes along one person's
just like
i don't want to do some of the work he
was like well would you propose this
idea to me
and then you're not going to do the
labor huh and and here's the tough part
and this is where people go crazy
it's like well i don't want to feel like
a responsibility
and i'm like that's so interesting so
you think someone has a responsibility
to give you exclusively but you don't
have the responsibility
to reciprocate sex how does that make
sense sway that's exactly what i said it
was like
so no so so she has the responsibility
to not do it anywhere else but you don't
have the responsibility
and people like sex should never be
responsibility on what planet
there's labors of emotion right you have
an emotional responsibility commitment
you have a time responsibility within a
relationship and you also have
a financial responsibility you've got
all kinds so why is it that when it
comes to the bedroom we're all like
there's no responsibilities
what now do not misinterpret what i'm
saying i'm not saying
if he says lay down and put out that you
have to do it that's not what i said
but it doesn't change the fact that you
have a responsibility you shouldn't do
anything against your will
but know that there's going to be
expectations yeah i don't know what job
you can come to where you're just like
i'm just not doing this today
and then still think you're supposed to
keep the job and no one's supposed to
say anything to you
what eventually it's going to catch up
it's going to cause problems so
yeah i do think there is a
responsibility both emotionally
physically all levels you're giving
yourself to somebody at some point your
boss is going to come down to you and be
like why you're not doing this job
maybe you have some valid answers yeah
but you're going to have to have that
conversation
yeah so now let's go back to what you
asked me you said to me you never
pressured me
to get married in 2007 we were living
together right
you said you no longer wanted to live up
with me and shack up with me
because you wanted to be my wife not my
girlfriend right because i wanted to
know where that don't sound like
pressure to you it sounds like me
voicing where i see my life going
hence why i said i'm gonna stay in my
lane because i didn't have all the
information what do you think
well yeah it's a fresh that's pressure
and then she goes she goes i pressured
you
yeah you did here's something
interesting you could pressure someone
and not be in the wrong
if you're saying i want to be married
that's something that i want that could
put pressure on the other person doesn't
make you wrong
the same way i could be dating a girl
for a long time she doesn't want to put
out because whatever
and i can be like i really want to do it
that could put pressure on her and i'm
not necessarily wrong
yeah there's no it's not a right or
wrong thing right here yeah it's a
pressure if it's just no pressure yeah
but it's not because you necessarily it
feels like it's pressure
that it's necessarily bad yes yeah i
understand that bad or not is gonna be
it's gonna be determined of how the
person's going to take it what about
being able to feel pressure what about
being aggressive behind it i
said we don't get a rush to get married
you said i don't want to be engaged
longer than a year
is that not pressure
that's me voicing my opinion about
it you're voicing it out i understand
but i mean when you put a date on
something
it's an ultimatum by this date
it should be dead that's an ultimatum
yes you're voicing it out and you do
ububu
and you should you should voice it out
again i'm not saying you're right or
wrong i don't think it's a right or
wrong thing
it's yes you voice it out but it's an
ultimatum an ultimatum is pressure it
sounds like pressure to me so you say
you want to be engaged
i get engaged you say you want to be
married within a year
we do that we get married then you make
it seem like
like this is a chore to your husband
once again i
ask the question why do women
who push forth monogamy on the man
they're dating
then get overwhelmed when that man who
tries to provide that monogamy to you
why do you get upset when we're trying
to be what you want us to be you don't
want me to be with no one else right
right i'm asking this is a serious
question yes you don't want me to be
with no one else absolutely so if i
decide that all this testosterone i have
i want to give to
you why is this so overwhelming now this
is what you asked for
such a funny way to stop i'm not trying
to bust all over you
try to try to shoot up your club it's
such an interesting way of putting it i
understand why he does that
and that's why i said i'm glad i said
that in the beginning i was like yo i'm
gonna stay in
my lane and i'm gonna listen to the
whole thing before i even say something
so what do you think
i understand where he's coming from it's
just a valid question
in his position in his position and what
i see is like okay you pressured me
you pressured me to do this you
pressured me to do that when i do
that then we come to we come to this and
that's not that's a true like
huh it's a choice something oh nothing
okay cool and i don't have you don't
have to say yes but i'm like
i can't so i gotta so okay
but you don't want okay
no no again
26 and 27 year old kadeen was like
okay here's the natural succession of
life you
graduate you're working you meet
somebody
you guys are dating you want children
yeah i want children yes
we don't want to wait too long or too
late to have children no now a lot of
people are waiting until their 30s to
have children and i understand why
we and we at that time felt like well
we're doing everything
in this natural succession that the
forces that be have given us this
timeline
however i did not realize that after
having children
after you know career changes all of the
turbulences that we've been through in
life
that that was going to have a direct
effect on my sex drive
i think it's cool that they're talking
about it if they're i i it's weird that
they're
putting it out there but it could be
useful for some people
you know i mean that's a brand new they
do these kind of things yeah they have
this podcast
i wouldn't do it but it can get people
to talk so it's great
it's great that they're having this
conversation what i one thing
i'll say people watch this and be like
oh my god they're gonna get divorced
soon
i think people don't realize what kind
of conversations happen within marriage
and how complicated they could be
and they can look just like that just
because people have very strong
disagreements doesn't mean that they're
like i'm cutting it loose and they've
been married for
well over a decade they seem fine so for
you to sit they'd be like they're gonna
get a divorce
it tells me that you don't really have a
really great concept of what commitment
looks like
because for a lot of people
conversations like this are perfectly
normal
yeah you think it's going to be easy
peasy lemon squeezy but sometimes it's
difficult difficult lemon difficulty i
mean it's not always
it thought it was you're going to have
this agreement yeah some of the lemons
are just
dry yeah some of them lemons are dry and
sometimes really lemon you understand
what i'm saying
i think it's very healthy that they're
having this conversation that they
broadcast it
that's another thing to each they own
but i think it's good that they're
having this conversation
in what way having conversation is bad
and you think you're cringing
you have to have this conversation i
understand his side i understand her
side yeah and you know this is a real
struggle for some ladies because after
having kids
after going through that stuff it
affects their hormone levels
everything's out of whack so
this is not a foreign phenomenon and so
in that sense i sympathize with their
with their position because it's a tough
one it's a it's a difficult one to
manage right body change
yeah you feel different differently
about everything yeah
it's not easy it's not an easy
discussion and it's not to be like
that's your job do it but there is a
discussion to be had period that's what
i think we're trying to do
um it's not that easy road yeah it's
difficult man
it's hard and you know some people might
say listen you need to be more creative
with how you approach the discussion
maybe you guys associate therapists for
this kind of stuff or maybe you guys try
to explore different ways of doing it
and like
try to expand the bedroom to maybe erase
that but sometimes those things are not
enough sometimes the wiring is just off
it's not to put blame it's not to do
this but it's like yo that causes
problems like if i got all this pent up
frustration of not being able to
and you're not gonna reciprocate and
there's nothing i could do it's gonna
cost
friction so at least being able to talk
about it
in a way that's conducive might be
helpful and i think it raises some good
questions
it raises good questions about some of
the difficulties that happens within a
long relationship
and then if you come at this discussion
you're like well why don't you just
leave the relationship well
sometimes it's more complicated way more
you know whether it's kids involved
whether it's
your lives are so intertwined you don't
just quit on a marriage
on a relationship because one aspect is
completely missing but you also don't
just tolerate things that are completely
missing
because you want to stay committed there
has to be a middle ground as the great
uh steve harvey said
there's no such thing as a plan b yeah
yeah yeah and if you want to fix things
you got to talk about it right that's it
if you want something you got to ask for
it you have not because you
asked not and i think that's what he was
having this conversation about
it's an interesting question maybe for
some of those women they gotta let the
man go yeah i mean
let them go uh you know get some side
boots
some of them do some of them do i know
yeah so just something to think about
but we want to hear your perspective
maybe you guys got a different
perspective than us we'd love to hear
from you guys ladies by all means go in
the comments and go him
uh but we want to hear from you yes what
every time you say ladies
ladies poppy
[Music]
me
oh